c'est une histoire virales comme il en
existe beaucoup sur internet celle d'une
vidéo qui émeut et d'une cagnotte de
soutien qui est lancé cette fois ci
c'est le jeune quaid n 1 australien âgé
de neuf ans et atteint de nanisme acquis
dans une vidéo filmée par sa maman
s'exprime en larmes sur le harcèlement
dont ils seraient victimes à l'école en
raison de son handicap
maintenant
une vidéo terrible qui a immédiatement
fait le tour des réseaux sociaux est ému
des millions d'internautes pour l'aider
à se reconstruire et a retrouvé le
sourire de nombreuses célébrités se sont
mobilisés pour financer une cagnotte
en quelques jours ce ne sont pas moins
de 500 mille dollars qui ont été
récoltés un joli conte de fées mais qui
aurait pu tourner au cauchemar car dans
le même temps certaines personnes
prétendent que le jeune homme serait un
escroc en consultant son compte
instagram certains ont retrouvé des
photos qui indiquerait qu'il aurait en
fait 18 ans et non devant comme il le
prétend mais les journalistes ont bien
mené l'enquêté ont prouvé que le jeune
garçon aurait bel et bien neuf ans et
autres zones d'ombré l'attitude de quoi
ils donnent sur les réseaux sociaux
alors qu'il n'a pas encore dix ans on
peut le retrouver sur plusieurs clichés
habillé en marque de luxe de la tête aux
pieds contenant des liasses de billets
et faisant même des doigts d'honneur
une attitude qui pour certains
prouverait qu'il s'agit bien d'un coup
de buzz pour faire parler de 8,6 à
l'heure actuelle toute la vérité autour
de cette affaire n'a pas encore été fait
rien ne prouve réellement jusqu'à
maintenant que l'histoire de quoi y
donne serait un canular une chose est
sûre cette affaire aura permis au monde
entier d'ouvrir les yeux sur les
problèmes de discrimination que peuvent
rencontrer au quotidien les personnes de
petite taille
alors qu'elle a des infos là dessus qui
a suivi cette affaire on a tous suivi en
ce week-end c'est l affaire du week-end
oui valérie kelly alors en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'effectivement une
fois que ça a ému le monde entier le
premier à s'en émouvoir 7 et hugh
jackman hugh jackman qui à mon premier
tweet et après de nombreuses célébrités
sont venues soutenir
quaden et évidemment et à ce moment là
il ya une sorte de bascule qui s'est
opérée parce que comme toujours c'est le
pire et le meilleur sur les réseaux
sociaux détaillé farfouiller sur sur
instagram et sur l'instinct graves
notamment il y avait une photo de lui
avec un nu un chiffre 18
or il se trouvait que c'était passé 18
ans qu'il fêtait mais les 18 ans d'un
copain à partir de là la rumeur a enflé
en disant ce n'est pas un enfant il a 18
ans puis voilà que les alors moi j'ai un
petit peu regardé ce que je fais
beaucoup d'insomnie alors j'ai regardé
tous les tweets qui avait à ce sujet là
je suis tombé sur le twitt de nadine
morano là votre copine nadine morano
elle imagine un wilmotte dean ball a
ajouté un petit peu choqué parce que le
hashtag joséphine ange gardien
je me suis dit quand même oui c'est vrai
qu'elle a mis nadine morano quelle
cruauté stop total soutien à quoi donne
un petit câlin de joséphine ange gardien
il aurait dû bien fallu faire une petite
barque à nadine morano on sait qu'elle
fait pas de spectacle non plus hein les
panneaux
c'est pas ce n'est pas la grande marque
haddadou morano alors on a avec nous
emilie merci d'être là emilie et me dit
vous avez quel âge 2010 j'ai 21 ans 21
ans vous êtes magnifique merci mais
magnifique alors vous êtes vous avez
vous êtes atteint de petite taille vous
êtes petit jeu vous êtes petit se
mesurer combien à mettre entre 1 m 33
alors il ya un vrai tabou dit autour des
personnes de petite taille quand vous
avez vu toute cette affaire vous est-ce
qu'à l'école vous étiez discriminer ce
que vous senti mal ouais vraiment comme
la plupart comme la plupart des enfants
malheureusement atteints de pathologies
qui fait qu'on a des petites tailles et
d'autres maladies
c'est vrai que du moment qu'on est à
l'école tant que tant qu'on ne vit pas
sa scolarité ça continue après quand on
devient adulte ça continue aussi dans la
vie d'adulte
c'est pourtant le sait quand vous
entendez sais quoi qui voudront passer
quand est ce que vous vous sentez de
regard des gens qui aimaient qui est
curieux sur vous sentez il ya des
insultes ya déjà des moqueries alors il
ya beaucoup de rires d'accord énormément
derrière montauban qu'un personnellement
énormément de lire dans mon dos quand je
passe devant les jours dans la rue elle
ça avec le temps forcément les reconnaît
rossano est dédié et c'est très
douloureux c'est vraiment effectivement
il ya aussi des gens qui vont avoir plus
de culot et qui vont avoir le culot de
vous insulter à coeur ouvert comme ça il
ya des gens qui vous insultent et déjà
de quoi ça a été un gars petite insulte
comme le jardin où ça pouvait partir
très loin après ça a été des insultes
vraiment j'ai pas à certains moments de
la vie j'ai été traitée vraiment comment
pire qu'un animal parce que même un
animal on ne peut pas le traiter un
enfant c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qui vous
arrive et qu'est ce que vous faisiez
vous faisait quoi en fait c'était pour
les exemples mais c'était donc des
insultes après c'était des ondes
rabaisser en permanence des en fait dès
que j'essayais de faire quelque chose
comme tout le monde comme les gens de
mon âge on me stopper net en fait parce
que d'après comme j'étais petit j'avais
pas moi de faire capteront c'était pas
possible
les gens ne pouvaient pas accepter de
voir faire les choses comme tu es petit
tu as pas le roi tu tu fermes ta bouche
heureusement et tu restes dans ton coin
vous êtes français vous avez je suis
fiancée je n'ai pas d'enfant vous assure
c'est avec une personne de petite taille
avec une personne de taille normale 1
mètre 90 et lui il a craqué sur vous
mais je compose je le comprends parce
que prochain vous êtes manipulés
magnifique d'en rigoler quand il est
chaud on pense souvent la question pour
ses potes tous à skis comment il vous a
présenté comment ça s'est passé
mais il m'a présenté comme en présence
de sa copine normal exactement ya pas il
ya quand même eu deux voilà non non
parce que moi c'est ça ce conte jeu
toujours vrai dire et toutes les
personnes atteintes d'un douala de
petite taille bourde voilà ce qu'ils
veulent c'est juste être traitée
normalement c'est à dire être voilà doit
pas être traitée différemment mais voilà
on sait malheureusement c'est un
possible cessez jamais possible même
dans le travail même temps l'amour dans
l'air général c'est pas possible
cette chanteuse je suis chanteuse
d'accord vous chantez quoi dans des dans
des soirées dans des noms jeu va je suis
dans une agence actuellement donc là on
a fini en album et après on oui ça
m'arrive ce fonds a chanté en tire un
peu là où l'on verrait l'album va le
faire écouter mais un problème
et aujourd'hui vous sentez comment est
ce que vous sentez qu'il ya moins de
moqueries ou sont et c'est pareil cas il
convient là toujours autant après moi je
pense que quand on devient adulte ont
mûri forcément d'accord donc c'est
personnellement c'est plus ma priorité
je pense que j'ai plein d'autres belles
choses à faire au lieu de penser à un
rythme moins atteintes par les critiques
par les moqueries
comme si ça entendre j'en entends tout
le temps je vais je vais sortir de chez
moi je vais marcher dans la rue je vais
avoir 3 4 d'heure d'office des petites
mesbah adepte des petits et vire à
droite à gauche mais quand je rentre
chez moi le soir je vais pas m'apitoyer
là dessus j'ai vraiment eu un put alors
il ya l'oxycodone qui parlait lui c'est
pour ça que ça fait un buzz énorme qui
parle de suicide
est-ce que vous au moment où vous êtes
dit voilà je suis bi trop de moqueries
je suis trop de voix là de deux colis b
est ce que je me dis ça alors j'ai eu
une période bien sûr à l'adolescence
ouais alors moi j'ai jamais eu
c'est vrai que j'ai eu des idées noires
j'ai eu pas mal d'idées noires mais j'ai
jamais essayé de passer à la
mais ça a été très très dur à
l'adolescence parce que c'est là qu'on
prend conscience de ce qu'on est
les comprends qu'on sorte de ce qu'on
saura plus tard je me suis dit je peux
pas vivre comme ça encore toute ma vie
c'est pas possible vu comme c'était dur
mais c'est dur on n'acceptera jamais je
n'arriverai à rien puisque ça on ne leur
a pas chez aussi tu es petit tu feras
jamais rien ta vie les gens petit comme
ça on n'en veut pas en tout cas et midi
sachez que vous êtes magnifique merci
sur un petit bisou à ma chérie tu
n'écoutes pas des critiques tu es très
belle et bien dans sa peau voilà qui lui
vittavi kif et fait nous des belles
chansons voilà d'accord ça m'a fait un
gros bisou merci mine est en tout cas
d'avoir à calais
[Applaudissements]